metro police arresting new orleans
running back alvin kamara for allegedly
attacking somebody in a nightclub on the
strip police arrested alvin kamaragan
after the pro bowl game at allegiance
sunday kamara posted bond last night no
longer in custody he is charged with
battery resulting in substantial bodily
harm the charge is a felony and kamara
could face prison time if convicted
and a court hearing for kamara scheduled
for today that appearance was moved
until march so now we're learning more
about what led to the arrest of the new
orleans saints star victoria saha
joining us now to walk us through what
happened
we're getting new information
surrounding the events that took place
here at dre's nightclub leading up to
alvin kamara's arrest in an arrest
report metro police responded to sunrise
hospital saturday evening the victim
darnell green told police from his
hospital bed that he was leaving dre's
nightclub on the strip early saturday
morning and as he was stepping onto the
elevator with a large group next to him
a man later identified as alvin kamara
put his hand on green's chest stopping
him from walking onto the elevator green
then pushed camaro's hand off green
tells police he was hit and kicked by
multiple people but greene was able to
remember kamara's involvement and police
say security footage supports green's
accusations camaro did play in the pro
bowl on sunday and he was taken into
custody after the game at a legion
stadium he was released on a 5 thousand
dollar bond and will be facing the judge
on march 8. reporting from the las vegas
trip victoria saha live local now
and by the way kamara is one of the most
popular players in the league his arrest
is the latest setback for the nfl as it
tries to promote a positive brand kamara
is the face of the new orleans saints
franchise he also works with nascar as
part of its social justice movement